[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen allen es gibt einen
Anlass zum Feiern aber gibt es auch
einen Grund und ist uns nach Feiern
zumute 32 Jahre deutsche Einheit die
Überwindung der Teilung unseres Landes
ohne Blutvergießen durch eine friedliche
Bürgerbewegung wenn das kein Grund sein
sollte und gleichzeitig sagen immer noch
viele wirklich geglückt sei diese
Einheit nicht und gleichzeitig entstehen
neue Zweifel am Zustand eines Staates
der an Bürokratie zu ersticken scheint
in dem sich überall Baustellen auftun
und Abhilfe ewig auf sich warten lässt
symbolisch repräsentiert durch Schilder
an den Autobahnen die den dort jeden Tag
im Stau steckenden versprechen die
marode Brücke sei fertig bis Mitte 2019
da messen Meinungsforscher einen Verlust
an Vertrauen in Politik und Demokratie
ganz generell der erschrecken muss es
gibt viel zu besprechen gleich hier bei
uns und natürlich auf dem traditionellen
Bürgerfest dieses Jahr in Erfurt dort
ist Melanie Haag
Mannheim
Künstler wie ist die Lage der Nation
also ein bisschen aufgeheizt würde ich
sagen also das erfahre ich auch hier auf
der Brücke die Leute haben echt
irgendwie das Druck dahinter teilweise
also Sorgen und Nöte drei zwei das Logo
der zentralen Einheitsfeier in Erfurt
als Kunstwerk
Applaus ja wir wollen feiern den Tag der
Deutschen Einheit wir wollen aber auch
auf die Sorgen aufmerksam machen
drei Tage Party in einer ungewissen Zeit
zusammen wachsen ist das Motto und nach
32 Jahren noch immer ein Prozess im
Westen sehen laut ZDF Politbarometer 57%
mehr Gemeinsamkeiten im Osten dagegen
stehen für 57% die Unterschiede im
Vordergrund
ich denke das ist noch nicht
zusammengewachsen wird auch so schnell
nicht zusammenwachsen es gibt immer noch
Vorbehalte bei uns gibt es kein Ost- und
West mehr alles eins Lohnunterschiede
oder auch so zwischenmenschliche
Unterschiede wird immer geben Stichwort
Verdienst 2021 bekamen ostdeutsche im
Schnitt
12.200 Euro weniger als die Kollegen im
Westen
Juliane Stückrath ist Autorin und
Kommunalpolitikerin in Thüringen weil
sie mitentscheiden will die Ethnologin
hat ein Buch geschrieben über
Ostdeutschland und den Blick darauf
wir haben also seit 30 Jahren das
Phänomen dass sich die Bilder von den
ostdeutschen sehr verfestigt und
verhärtet haben und dass die scheinbar
im Erklären auch noch funktionieren aber
die verschleiern das ostdeutsche sehr
viel differenzierter zu betrachten sind
und auch gerade die Ostdeutschen
Biografien eben nicht so einheitlich
verlaufen sind
geprägt durch Umbrüche damals und heute
wieder der Krieg in der Ukraine die
Energiekrise viele Herausforderungen die
die Menschen im Osten auf die Straße
treiben mit der politischen Reaktion der
Bundesregierung auf den Ukraine Krieg
sind in ganz Deutschland 64 Prozent
unzufrieden von denen Glauben elf
Prozent im Osten dass die Sanktionen
verfehlt sind im Westen nur 5%
100%ig die Sanktionen auf keinen Fall
sollte es mir mit Diplomatie auch
Europas sollte es mehr mit Diplomatie
machen die goldenen Geländer sollen eine
Erinnerung sein sagt Nina nielebok und
ein Denkanstoß für mehr Gemeinsamkeit
das Feiertags-Wochenende idealerweise
Zeit um durchzuatmen der Tag der
Deutschen Einheit guter Anlass um Ideen
zu finden für eine Situation heute in
der nicht Einheit sondern Zwist und
Polarisierung die Schlagzeilen bestimmen
die Biografie des ehemaligen
Bundespräsidenten Joachim Gauck ist in
besonderer Weise mit diesem Tag
verbunden Herr Bundespräsident guten
Abend
guten Abend und auch verbunden mit
diesem Ort aus dem sie heute bei uns
sind die Marienkirche in Rostock wo sie
während der friedlichen Revolution in
der DDR Andachten gehalten haben und
auch demonstrierten wenn Sie an diesen
Ort zurückblicken und gleichzeitig auf
heute was ist der wichtigste Schluss den
Sie unserem Land mitgeben würden für die
aktuellen Herausforderungen
ja dies ist hier ein Kraftort hier haben
Menschen 1989 sich versammelt und sind
aus diesen Kirchen hier Marienkirche
Leipzig Nikolaikirche raus auf die
Straßen und demonstriert gegen die
Diktatur und das wichtigste damals war
wirklich das allerwichtigste dass wir
unsere Angst verlieren konnten und wir
mussten uns da gegenseitig ermutigen das
war nicht so einfach Angst war lange
eingeübt und ging mit uns all die
Jahrzehnte und jetzt ging es darum
unsere Angst den Abschied zu geben und
wissen Sie was das geht man kann
Ängste nicht wegzaubern aber man kann
sie zähmen und man kann so etwas wie Mut
und Entschlossenheit fassen und daran
erinnert uns so eine Kirche daran
erinnert uns dieser Tag der Deutschen
Einheit also
Ängste sind menschlich aber Mut ist auch
menschlich
Ängste und Mut jetzt haben die Deutschen
grundlegende Zweifel darüber werden wir
vielleicht gleich noch reden bleiben wir
mal aktuell bei dem was den Menschen
tatsächlich ganz konkret auch Ängste ist
aktuell Inflation hohe Energiepreise das
kann man ja tatsächlich verstehen wie
muss denn eine Regierung damit umgehen
um diese Ängste zu nehmen oder zumindest
das Gefühl zu geben sie bekommen die
Lage in den Griff
ich glaube wir haben eine Menge
Erfahrung sammeln können in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und zwar das tiefe Täler zu
überwinden waren und dass das auch
gelungen ist und das gelingt natürlich
besonders gut wenn wir eine Regierung
haben die entschlossen ist die ihre
Entschlossenheit zeigt und die der
Bevölkerung erklärt was genau jetzt
geschieht in diesem Fall welche
Personengruppen welche Teile der
Industrie welche Teile des Handwerks
unterstützt werden sollen wenn es um
diese enormen Preise gibt geht die jetzt
bezahlt werden müssen im Herbst und im
Winter und dazu brauchen wir etwas was
wir schon einmal erlebt haben in
Deutschland und zwar als die große
Finanzkrise kam da hatten wir eine
Regierung die voller Entschlossenheit
den Bürgern signalisiert hat fürchtet
euch nicht um euer Erspartes und die
Deutschen die sonst ganz gerne Angst
haben sind dann völlig normal geblieben
und sind nicht hysterisch geworden und
deshalb brauchen wir kraftvolle
politische Führung die gleichzeitig im
Stande ist das was sie im Sinn hat und
tun wird auch den Menschen so zu
erklären dass sie es wirklich verstehen
haben wir denn diese Führung gerade oder
anders gefragt kann man nach dem großen
Wort der Zeitenwende weitermachen mit
Wumms und doppelwumms
ich weiß wo sie mich hinlocken wollen
Herr sie was aber ich will es mal so
ausdrücken wir erleben gerade dass die
Politik in einem Lernprozess ist und da
ist der eine ein bisschen schneller als
der andere es geht darum mit einer
erhellenden Vereinfachung auch komplexe
Sachverhalte unter die Menschen zu
bringen dass die begreifen die da oben
die wir gewählt haben die sorgen sich um
uns die machen sich bewusst in welchen
Schwierigkeiten wir sind und wenn dies
gelingt dass wir in einer solchen Weise
mit den Menschen sprechen dann ist
dieses kostbare gutes Vertrauens eben
auch nicht dahin sondern das kann wieder
wachsen und wir haben im Moment so ein
volatiles Situation das eben sehr viele
Menschen das Vertrauen verloren haben
und darum brauchen wir ganz klar
gesprochen nicht nur die Ansage der
zeitenwände die unglaublich wichtig war
sondern wir brauchen auch eine Politik
die dieser Ansage entspricht und da ist
es nötig dass wir uns kräftig
miteinander manchmal streiten aber
erstmal austauschen was erwarten wir in
Bezug auf die Inflation in Bezug auf die
Preise aber vor allen Dingen in Bezug
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine denn hier
ist das angsthema ja auch virulent
bleiben wir weil sie gerade angesprochen
haben beim Krieg in der Ukraine dem
russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine jetzt
stellen wir gerade in Ostdeutschland
erstaunlich viel Verständnis bei vielen
Menschen zumindest für Vladimir Putin
und seine Haltung fest im viel mehr als
im Westen in Polen etwa das ja auch sehr
stark unter dem Kommunismus gelitten hat
ist das komplett anders warum ist das
aus ihrer Ansicht so
ja weil die Deutschen nicht diese
Erfahrung haben dass es sich unbedingt
lohnt für die Freiheit zu kämpfen wir
haben eine schwere Niederlage erlitten
die ostdeutsche Bevölkerung 1953 am 17
Juni während die Sowjets nicht in
Deutschland Ost gewesen mit ihren
Panzern wäre im Jahr 54 wahrscheinlich
die Einheit gekommen weil das Volk
damals freie Wahlen wollte Demokratie
Freiheit das alles ist nicht passiert
und in Ostdeutschland gibt es so eine
verlängerte Erinnerung an die eigene
Ohnmacht das fühlt sich aber nicht gut
an und darum wird das umgedeutet dass es
so ein bisschen eine psychologische
Frage man fürchtet sich vor dem der
einen selber lange Jahre in Ohnmacht
gehalten hat und man schaut in lieber
etwas freundlicher an damit er uns
nichts Böses tut das ist in merkwürdiges
Phänomen und ich kann damit auch nicht
gut klarkommen vor allen Dingen weil wir
in der medialen Wahrnehmung oft so sehen
dass ein Drittel der ostdeutschen die so
tickt dass die eine wichtige Rolle
einnehmen als zwei Drittel die eine ganz
andere Auffassung haben und auch anders
wählen als diese an dieses eine Drittel
dass ich jetzt dann von links außen
rechts außen mit Querdenkern und schief
Denkern zusammen auf die Straße da habe
ich ein paar Probleme mit und das wird
sich auch ändern und noch eins die Angst
die hier bei uns vielfach auch vor den
Drohungen Putins an den Tag gelegt wird
die sehen wir in den Nachbarländern
nicht so wie bei uns in Deutschland und
es ist unglaublich wichtig dass wir uns
klar machen Putin preist diese Angst der
deutschen ein in seine Planung das ist
ein Element seiner Kriegführung und
deshalb brauchen wir eine nüchterne
Bewertung seiner Drohungen und eine ganz
klare Erkenntnis dass Angst kleine Augen
macht uns in die Flucht treibt und
Flucht ist alles was wir uns nicht
leisten können da ist ein Land
überfallen worden es gibt ein klares
Opfer wir haben diesem Land beizustehen
und auch deshalb nicht nur weil es
moralisch ist sondern auch deshalb weil
die da unsere Interessen vertreten die
Freiheit und die Demokratie wird
angegriffen unsere Freiheit und
Demokratie wird letztlich angegriffen
sie sind ein ermutiger sagen sie von
sich selbst Herr Gauck sie sind damals
von den Demonstrierenden 1989 in der
Marienkirche der sie jetzt stehen in
Rostock auch dazu geholt worden weil man
einen begnadeten Redner suchte sie haben
auch als Bundespräsident immer auch
durch ihr Charisma gewirkt ihr Tipp um
einen dunklen Herbst und Winter zu
meistern was würden Sie sagen
erstens die Situation anschauen wie sie
wirklich ist wir leben in Deutschland
immer noch in einem sehr gediegenen
Wohlstand die allermeisten Menschen und
für die die nicht im Wohlstand leben
sorgt dieser Staat wir sind nicht China
und wir sind nicht irgendwo in Afrika
sondern wir haben ein Sozialstaat
zweitens wenn wir dies wahrnehmen dann
wird der Tiefe Frust sich wandeln in
einen gewissen Unmut und wenn wir
Freunde treffen wenn wir uns mit
Menschen treffen und uns über die
Situation unterhalten haben wir schon
mal den ersten Schritt getan unseren
Unmut zu bekämpfen und im Übrigen
sollten wir ins Tun geraten es gibt ein
Element wer erinnern uns an Krisen die
wir mit gemeistert haben und da gibt es
viele unter anderem haben wir die
Diktatur besiegt und der Westen hat
einen super Rechtsstaat und eine super
Demokratie aufgebaut das ist das eine
woran wir uns erinnern was wir können
und das andere ist dass wir ins Tun
geraten nicht nur ins ängstliche
abwarten sondern dass wir gestalten dass
wir Putin durch Sanktionen schwächen
dass wir ihm zeigen das Recht geht nicht
einfach in die Flucht sondern wir stehen
dem überfallenen bei dass wir aktiv sind
und dass wir was die Politik betrifft
und unsere Ängste unserer Regierung
sagen sagt uns was ihr vorhabt und
erklärt es uns so dass wir zu Euch
Vertrauen gewinnen oder Vertrauen wieder
gewinnen der Appell von Joachim Gauck im
ZDF heute journal Herr Bundespräsident
vielen Dank
ich danke Ihnen auf Wiedersehen
das Gespräch haben wir vor einer Stunde
aufgezeichnet es gibt immer Licht wenn
wir nur mutig genug sind es zu sehen
wenn wir nur mutig genug sind es zu sein
hat die großartige junge Poetin Amanda
Gorman gesagt so gesehen strahlt es
gerade heller denn je aus Teheran Shiraz
Jast und ist verharren der Iran ein
einziges Leuchten das Regime der molars
geht vor nach dem Lehrbuch für Despoten
mit polizeiprügeln Gefängnisstrafen
gedrosselt im Internet die Protestwelle
bekommt es nicht in den Griff im
Gegenteil die Zahl der Demonstranten
wächst und es geht längst nicht mehr
allein um Kopftuch und Freiheitsrechte
es geht um das Regime selbst Lück
wahlport mit mir
ihr werdet uns nicht mehr los wir sind
da jeden Tag sprechöre heute in
kehrmannschein im kurdischen West Iran
und in der Pilgerstadt Mascha dem Osten
des Landes
[Applaus]
trotz brutaler Repression trotz
Internetsperren finden sich täglich
Tausende in vielen Städten zusammen mit
dem Ruf nach Selbstbestimmung und
Freiheit die Zahl der Verhaftungen
steigt vor allem unter Studentinnen und
Studenten
einige Hochschulprofessoren haben einen
unterrichtsboykott verkündet bis die
Studierenden wieder auf freiem Fuß sind
blutiger Auseinandersetzungen zwischen
Demonstranten und Polizei gab es gestern
in saidan an der Grenze zu Pakistan die
Behörden sprechen von mindestens 19
Toten die Wut der Bevölkerung entlud
sich als bekannt wurde das Tage zuvor
ein Polizeioffizier eine 15-jährige
vergewaltigt haben soll die Machthaber
versuchen unterdessen weiter die
Proteste klein zu reden sie machen ihre
ans Feinde im Ausland verantwortlich
diese fehlgeleiteten Jugendlichen werden
doch von Amerika aufgestachelt gegen die
islamische Republik aber sie werden
keinen Erfolg haben der General kündigte
Rache an massive Vergeltung für jeden
Angriff auf regimekräfte
News darin der Apparat setzt auf Gewalt
und Propaganda Parolen das Parlament
beriet gestern sichtbarstes Ergebnis
pathetische Unterstützung der
ultrakonservativen Hardliner für den
Mann an der Spitze
wir geben unser Leben für dich unser
Führer skandieren sie ein Plan sich
konstruktiv mit den Forderungen der
eigenen Bürger auseinanderzusetzen wurde
nicht vorgelegt
die Probleme leugnen das halten selbst
viele Anhängerinnen des Regimes für
keine Lösung auch hier wächst die Kritik
am rigidenkurs zur Durchsetzung des
kopftuchzwangs
ich bin weder für noch gegen die
Sittenpolizei aber sie sind sicher ein
Grund dafür dass viele Frauen in Iran
leiten
auch wenn das Kopftuch Pflicht ist
sollte es auf keinen Fall in so
unzumutbarer Weise durchgesetzt werden
[Musik]
die kopftuch-proteste so schwand es
einigen im Apparat könnten eine Lawine
ins Rollen bringen die die Islamische
Republik am Ende unter sich begräbt
schon mal älter sie greifen ja selbst
Krankenwagen an jetzt geht es nur gegen
das Kopftuch als nächstes verbrennen sie
den Koran und dann brennen die Moscheen
Frauen Leben Freiheit dafür gehen die
Iranerinnen weiter auf die Straße es
überfordert das erste Regime der alten
Männer mehr als alles andere
es gibt heute abend neue Hilferufe wir
Twitter aus Iran die unabhängig von uns
aktuell nicht zu überprüfen sind darin
geht es vor allem um die gespannte Lage
an den Universitäten in der
sharif-universität in Teheran soll eine
große Zahl von protestierenden Studenten
eingeschlossen sein es sein Schüsse zu
hören
wir behalten die Situation im Blick
aber erst haben wir weitere Nachrichten
von diesem Sonntag mit dir Heinz zur
Situation in der Ukraine im Süden soll
es weitere Gefechte gegeben haben im
Osten hat die Ukraine nach eigenen
Angaben jetzt wieder die Kontrolle über
die strategisch wichtige Stadt Liman
Präsident selenski erklärte in einer
kurzen videoansprache der Ort sei
vollständig von den russischen
Streitkräften geräumt und die
ukrainische Armee wolle weitere Orte
zurückerobern südöstlich von Liman nahe
der Front bereiten sie ihre Waffen
darauf vor
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
hat nach Ihrem Besuch in der Ukraine
weitere Waffenlieferungen für das Land
angekündigt wie sie der ARD sagte
gehören dazu 16 rath-haubitzen für das
kommende Jahr in der Slowakei produziert
und gemeinsam mit Dänemark Norwegen und
Deutschland finanziert würden
in Brasilien schließen in diesen Minuten
die Wahllokale 156 Millionen Menschen
waren heute aufgerufen einen neuen
Präsidenten zu wählen und zur Wahl
standen der Amtsinhaber der
Rechtspopulist bolsonaro und der linke
Ex-Präsident Julia da Silva der könnte
laut letzten Umfragen 50% erreichen und
so schon im ersten Wahlgang gewinnen
bolsonaro der in Umfragen nur bei 36
Prozent lag streute im Wahlkampf Zweifel
am Wahlsystem und gab an das Ergebnis
nur wie er sagte bei sauberen Wahlen zu
akzeptieren
nach Deutschland die AFD Niedersachsen
kämpft gerade mit auffällig vielen
Austritten von Mandatsträgern was aus
zwei Gründen für die Partei jetzt hoch
problematisch ist erstens in einer Woche
wählt Niedersachsen einen neuen Landtag
und zweitens die eigenen Leute lassen
kein gutes Haar an ihrer bisherigen
politischen Heimat was sie erzählen geht
weit über interne Querelen und
zerrüttetes Vertrauen hinaus es wächst
sich aus zu einem Skandal in dem jetzt
die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt der
Bericht von Peter Kunz Mollen ilau und
David Gebhardt
beste Umfragewerte für die AFD in
Niedersachsen sie profitiert vom
krisenherbst siegerlaune hat der
stellvertretende Landesvorsitzende
Ansgar schlede sowieso seit sich sein
Lager im internen Machtkampf
durchgesetzt hat auch gegen den Richter
Christopher Emden der selbst einmal
stellvertretender afd-vorsitzender in
Niedersachsen war und austrat mit diesen
harten Worten die Partei entwickelt sich
zu einem Sammelbecken für Versager
Gangster für Menschen die auf
unterschiedlichen wirtschaftlichen
Problemlagen kommen und versuchen wir
Mandate und Posten sich wirtschaftlich
zu sanieren und da wird mit allen
Bandagen gekämpft deshalb spreche ich
von beutegemeinschaft bis zu den Wahlen
am kommenden Sonntag ist Emden noch
niedersächsischer Abgeordneter einen
sicheren Listenplatz für den nächsten
Landtag hätte er bezahlen müssen sagt er
ich kandidieren wollen dann hätte ich
mir Stimmen kaufen müssen und ein Betrag
ungefähr 4.000 Euro war im Gespräch
angesprochen wurde ich von der Stelle
der ja eben die kriegsklasse verwaltet
und wohl auch der einzige ist nämlich an
der den Kontozugriff hat Zahlungen um
einen Listenplatz zu bekommen und eine
geheime Kasse geführt von dem Mann der
bei der AFD auf Platz 2 für die
niedersächsische Landtagswahl steht ja
also kann ich ihn überhaupt nicht zu
sagen ist vollkommener Mumpitz höre ich
jetzt das erste mal und
woher kommt das also dabei gehen die zu
klärenden Vorwürfe noch weiter auch
niedersächsische afd-kandidaturen für
den amtierenden Bundestag seien so
bezahlt worden mit monatlichen Abgaben
auf ein Konto über das Ansgar Schledde
offenbar verfügen kann die Kontonummer
liegt auch dem ZDF vor
die Staatsanwaltschaft Hannover hat nach
Eingang einer Strafanzeige einen
Ermittlungsverfahren wegen des
Anfangsverdachts der Untreue eingeleitet
weitere Auskünfte kann ich gegenwärtig
dazu aber nicht erteilen der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der AFD
Niedersachsen fühlt sich verleumdet sein
ex-parteifreund bedroht mir wurde
unmittelbar nach meinem Austritt überall
Mittelsmann gesagt dass wenn ich hier
jemanden der daran verstrickt ist zu
nahe kommen würde womit halt gemeint ist
mein Wissen
kundtun würde dann würde es an
körperlichen Angriff auf meine Person
geben den afd-aussteiger stößt ab wie
die Gewaltbereitschaft in der Partei
zunimmt in einem Rundbrief des
Kreisverbandes Nienburg Schaumburg wird
Bewaffnung in der Krise empfohlen wie
man sich wehrt am besten tötet oder
plündert
der Verfasser immerhin stellvertretender
Kreisvorsitzender ist im
niedersächsischen wahlkampfendsport
dabei
interessant was sie so alles haben ne
was ist denn das weiß ich nicht oder
sie das geschrieben haben also ich weiß
nicht was sie von mir wollen aber
ich möchte dazu ist keine Stellung
nehmen weil sie kennen sich mit Waffen
ja gut aus wenn wir in diesem Newsletter
liest mich mit schlechter Politik aus
waffentipps und Streitigkeiten um eine
vermeintliche Kriegskasse auch so sieht
die Alternative für Deutschland in
Niedersachsen aus
fußball ist die schönste Nebensache der
Welt heißt es gern Fußball kann
furchtbare Folgen haben aus Indonesien
kommen Meldungen heute von einer der
schwersten stadionkatastrophen der
Geschichte es geht gar nicht mal um das
Spiel selbst es geht um Ausschreitungen
danach um einen aus dem Ruder gelaufenen
Tränengaseinsatz der Polizei um eine
Massenpanik
125 tote mindestens Normen Odenthal
Seite an Seite werden sie begraben die
Brüder Ahmed und Mohammed
14 und 15 Jahre alt wie sollen die
Eltern das verstehen die Geschwister es
war doch ein Abend den die beiden Jungs
so sehr herbei gesehen hatten
sie haben Fußball geliebt aber sie waren
vorher nie im Stadion das war das erste
Spiel dass sie live gesehen haben
das erste Spiel das letzte Spiel für die
Brüder und so viele andere das Drama
begann mit dem schlusspliff sofort
stürmten Fans der heimannschaft Arima
von den Rängen auf den Rasen offenbar
wollten sie ihrer Wut über die
Niederlage Luft machen die Situation
komplett außer Kontrolle aufgebrachte
Fans rigorose Polizisten eine Eskalation
die sich später kaum noch begreiflich
erklären lässt
die Fans wollten die Spieler zur Rede
stellen die Sicherheitskräfte mussten
einschreiten um das zu unterbinden dabei
haben sie Tränengas eingesetzt denn sie
wurden angegriffen die Situation war
geradezu anarchisch
die Polizei Feuer Tränen Gas auf dem
Rasen und das ist besonders
verhängnisvoll auch auf die Ränge
tausende Menschen wollen nur noch weg
auf ihrer Flucht werden viele erdrückt
sie ersticken
Opfer der Massenpanik
das Tränengas war überall viele meiner
Freunde haben ihr Leben verloren weil
die Polizisten unmenschlich mit uns
umgegangen sind es war schrecklich
für Gäste-Fans aus Surabaya hatte es
keine Tickets gegeben aus
Sicherheitsgründen trotzdem war das
Stadion überfüllt 38.000 dürfen rein
42.000 waren da warum eine von vielen
Fragen ich ordne anders vorerst keine
Spiele in der Liga ausgetragen werden
erst müssen die Untersuchungen
abgeschlossen die Sicherheit verbessert
werden ich hoffe das war die letzte
Tragödie die sich im indonesischen
Fußball ereignet hat
denn indonesien hat große sportliche
Pläne im kommenden Jahr soll die U20 WM
ausgerichtet werden die Ereignisse der
Nacht aber sorgen für kalte Füße
wir sind im Gespräch mit dem
Fußball-Weltverband FIFA damit uns keine
Sanktionen treffen es dürfen keine über
alten Entscheidungen getroffen werden
die FIFA muss uns erst anhören wir
wollen ja aufklären wie diese Tragödie
zustande kam
von der FIFA kann man heute
Beileidsbekundungen mehr noch nicht ein
schwarzer Tag sei das für alle die den
Fußball lieben und da kann wohl keiner
widersprechen
[Musik]
das stimmt schlimme Bilder jetzt Fußball
der wirklich Sport ist mit dir eins ja
in der Fußball-Bundesliga da gab es
heute zwei Spiele Hertha BSC und 1899
Hoffenheim haben sich Unentschieden
getrennt eins zu eins und Schalke hat
gegen Augsburg zwei zu drei verloren
in der Formel 1 konnte sich Max
Verstappen beim Großen Preis von
Singapur heute nicht vorzeitig den
Weltmeistertitel sichern er wurde nur
Siebter über Platz 1 jubelte Teamkollege
sercho Perez sein erster Grand Prix Sieg
in Singapur Max Fürst tappen hat nun in
einer Woche in Suzuka die nächste Chance
auf die vorzeitige Titelverteidigung
heute hinter Peres auf den Plätzen 2 und
3 Charl Leclerc und Carlos Sainz
und wie geht es weiter die kommende
Woche in den traditionell jetzt in den
Blick was wird wichtig hier ist Benjamin
golowski
[Musik]
am Dienstag wird Bundeskanzler Scholz
mit den Ministerpräsident innen der
Länder beraten wie die beschlossenen
Entlastungen im Energiebereich auch an
die Bundesländer weitergegeben werden
können die fordern lautstark dass die
Länder die Unternehmen und die
Privathaushalte mit den hohen Kosten
nicht allein gelassen werden dürften
die ganze Woche über werden die
diesjährigen nobelpreisträger:innen
bekannt gegeben am Montag für Medizin
dann Physik und Chemie am Donnerstag
Literatur und am Freitag der
Friedensnobelpreis es wird die Woche der
klugen Köpfe die Welt braucht sie
und am Sonntag wird Niedersachsen dann
einen neuen Landtag wählen im letzten
Umfragen liegt Ministerpräsident weil
von der SPD knapp vor seinem
Herausforderer Bernd Althusmann von der
CDU die Grünen dahinter auf Platz 3 auch
bundespolitisch hat diese letzte
Landtagswahl des Jahres große Bedeutung
der Sonntag wird spannend
und noch zum Wetter es gibt aktuelle
Unwetterwarnungen des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird vor
ergiebigem Dauerregen in Regionen im
Süden von Bayern und jetzt die
Aussichten für morgen da ist es in der
Mitte und bis zum Erzgebirge dicht
bewölkt sonst zeigt sich nach
anfänglichem Nebel die Sonne bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 12 bis 18 Grad
der Wind weht an der Ostsee frisch teils
stürmisch um Nordwest in den nächsten
Tagen bleibt es nach Nebelauflösung
überwiegend trocken und sonnig bei 13
bis 21 Grad am Mittwoch bis zu 25 Grad
ja mit diesen bei einer sommerlichen
Aussichten beenden wir diesen
Nachrichten Sonntag im heute-journal
danke an sie alle dass sie dabei waren
morgen freut sich an dieser Stelle Maria
taslonka auf sie und die nächste heute
Express gibt zum 0.30 von uns allen an
sie ein sehr angenehmen Abend
[Musik]